world's longest sea bridge is now
officially open for traffic in China
took almost a decade to build the HCM B
bridge which spans 34 miles connecting
Hong Kong and Macau to mainland China
the critics point to the project's huge
costs and the reported 18 lives lost
during construction Ben Tracy is at the
bridge in Hong Kong the bridge opened
this morning and it could cut travel
times between certain cities from 3
hours to about 30 minutes but a lot of
people here in Hong Kong don't see this
as a good thing they see it as the
Chinese government tightening its grip
on this former British colony the
official opening of the world's longest
sea bridge is a major achievement for
China and its President Xi Jinping
building the Hong Kong zhuhai Macau
bridge was one of the most challenging
and costly infrastructure projects in
the world it spans China's Pearl River
Delta
connecting Hong Kong the gambling mecca
of Macau and nine other cities in
southern China with nearly 70 million
people the bridge is made of more than
400,000 tonnes of steel it's as long as
nearly 20 Golden Gate bridges two
artificial islands were built to link
underwater tunnels for vehicles so ships
can still pass through the busy Seaway
it costs nearly 20 billion dollars and
Hong Kong taxpayers were stuck with 60%
of the bill for a bridge many of them
will never use Hong Kong resident
Rebecca ko says it's meaningless for
normal Hong Kongers we rarely go to
mainland China Hong Kong a former
British colony operates under a
different system from the mainland it
allows certain rights such as freedom of
speech assembly and the press but
Beijing is exerting more control here
and cracking down on dissent the new
bridge as well as a newly opened 11
billion dollar bullet train that links
Beijing and Hong Kong are seen by many
as infrastructure propaganda Claudia mo
is a Hong Kong politician they still
need
as a political symbol icon to remind
whom compete that you are connected to
the motherland with this very grand
bridge isaac stonefish is a senior
fellow with the Asia Society a lot of
people in Hong Kong are worried that the
direction it's going in is bad for them
bad for freedom and bad for this idea of
a distinctive Hong Kong weather people
here like it or not this bridge is going
to be around for a long time it is
designed to withstand multiple natural
disasters and lasts for 120 years for
CBS this morning Ben Tracy Hong Kong no
doubt an engineering marvel but at an
expense to loss of 18 lives Ben thank
you